well joining us now to debate whether
softer jails that Dutch option and the
answer to Britain's prison crisis are
Jonathan Robinson and Bettina Jordan
barber Jonathan is a for a mate and now
a campaigner for prison reform and
Bettina who works as a prison consultant
has also served a 12-month sentence they
jumped in just watching that report
there and the dutch approach to the
prison system it's being called a softer
approach to what we see here do you
think that's a good idea to keep
reoffending rates down well
traditionally we're not very good at the
prison system here in this country we
have the highest reoffending rates in
the riffin incus 15 billion pounds I
think the majority of the public wants
people who have digressed the law
punished but when they come out to the
other end of the present journey
rehabilitated so they don't really know
and that's where we're failing soft
prisons hard prisons going to prison is
a pretty awful thing I fully deserved it
what I saw not going on was
life-changing you're not going to get
rehabilitated watching a cycle of
EastEnders Coronation Street and
Emmerdale being banged up 23 hours a day
purposeful activity in prisons has only
risen 1% in the last five years there
are small pockets of really good work
going on in the prison system a good
example is the clink charity that runs
prison restaurants top ten Tripadvisor
inmates have been through that program
their reoffending rate is now only 6%
the rest of the system lying at 75
percent we could be doing a lot more
with people what's been gotham in prison
and believe it or not many inmates want
to do stuff whether it's work or
training but behind the majority of the
walls is a huge huge pile of apathy
p'tee that's interesting it Jonathan
makes reference to the fact that
prisoners are sitting around all day
watching TV and a lot of people at home
will go well that is being soft on
prisoners they get access to a TV
they're just sit around all day watching
EastEnders you know are we soft in our
approach anyway getting softer giving
them microwaves keys to their own
if you know if that's not working at the
moment how's it gonna make it any better
but it's not a question of being soft
it's a question of being rehabilitative
effective and appropriate the current
system isn't working
clearly for the Dutch their system is
working as Jonathan said the current
reoffending rates annually cost this
country 15 billion pounds a year that's
15 billion pounds of UK taxpayers money
which is equivalent to what the City of
London pays in tax prison reform is not
popular and it's not a vote winner and
unless you decide as a country what you
want your prisons to be you're stuck
they need to be going to prison and
having the conviction is the punishment
if you want your institutions to be
places of revenge and places where
you're just going to constantly beat
that person down we appear to be doing a
good job of that at the moment the
Justice Secretary has stated that she
doesn't feel that reducing the number of
inmates is going to make any difference
I agree with that
there are present governor's have their
own reporting system it's called the
race the Oasis reports and all those
reports every prisoner is assessed as to
their risk of reoffending we've got
clients at the moment whose risk of
reoffending is deemed to be 1% and yet
they're still being made to serve the
last two years of their sentence if you
give them microwaves and you give them
their keys to their rooms which we do in
some prisons in this country already and
I don't think the general public
actually knows that as a general rule
you are supporting their punishment with
a degree of normalization and that
degree of normalization will assist
their rehabilitation in the future okay
this is confusing me I mean Jonathan our
places our prisons meant to be a place
of punishment or rehabilitation we sort
of confusing it - and nothing's getting
done but it and I think that's what
drives so much fear and uncertainty into
politicians there's the chief whip of
the MOJ is a gentleman called guy
Oppermann and he once said to me all
politicians are terrified of the Daily
Mail and the prison issue is not
election loser I agree all politicians
are absolutely terrified of the Daily
Mail
but Liz trusts in an interview at the
weekend confused the issue herself she
stated in one sentence that prisons had
to be places of punishment and reform
you can't have both
but we're sending too many people to
prison then who should be rehabilitated
outside the prison since we're going to
prison to be rehabilitated cause like if
they you know commit a drugs offense for
example should they not be put into a
rehabilitation center if you've got
someone who's got a drug problem that's
feeding their crime you need to treat
the addiction if you've got someone
who's in debt and has as a result of
their debt the debt is causing them to
commit crime they need to have debt
counseling if you've got someone who has
aggression and the aggressive behavior
is causing their problem then look at
anger management we've got enough
systems and enough digital digital
approaches GPS tagging you could put
severe bail conditions you could have
someone reporting three times a day if
you needed to they don't have to be in
prison rapists murderers those that pose
an absolute risk to society yes they
need to be in prison that's an
interesting point isn't it and one of
the things I've taken away from
Siobhan's report is that in the
Netherlands they do use Tanks a lot more
they issue fines a lot more for the sort
of people that in this country would be
sent to prison for short sentences short
amount of times and as a result for
fewer people in prisons and the ones
that are there perhaps can be given more
attention to help with life outside to
reduce rehabilitation surely that's not
a bad thing I think our European cousins
are far more laid-back and less baying
for blood when people have a digress the
law so you say the problem is the public
opinion yes but I say again through the
work I've been doing
I've picked up from the public in this
country that people the public wants
breakers of the law punished but fixed
was we've got them after the panorama
program last week awful awful president
program sir Martin Narey the ex-head of
the Prison Service said prison is a
golden opportunity to rehabilitate
people that we're missing it's still a
fact that you can enter prison now
illiterate stay in there five years ten
or twenty years and still come out
illiterate and an what what is going on
or what isn't going on you know the
Justice Secretary is worried about
releasing prisoners early and the effect
that might have an ineffective prison
system is far more dangerous than
releasing people who have been assessed
by the Prison Service themselves of a
low risk of offending releasing those
people slightly early and imposing
different restrictions on them outside
the Germans interested me we're
currently looking at removing criminals
convicted criminals driving licenses
from them because in Germany the biggest
put the biggest punishment you can give
someone is to stop them from driving ok
there's all sorts of alternatives that
could be looked at ok and Bettina Jordan
Barbra and Jonathan Robinson thank you
very much very interesting topic for
discussion